what would it look like to ride
alongside a beam of light this is a
question Einstein asked over a hundred
years ago now the trouble was he
couldn't actually do the experiment so
he had to use his imagination he had to
do a thought experiment to figure out
what a reasonable outcome would be
I could imagine there'd be some element
of Norcia
I'd imagine everything would get more
intense maybe it would confuse the brain
I don't really know if you'd be seeing
very much I was on a water slide just a
couple of days ago and I found that
really difficult
Einstein's intuition told him that the
world should feel the same in all frames
of reference moving with constant
velocity these are called inertial
frames of reference so it doesn't matter
if you're in a train or on a plane or in
a car or in a room as long as you're
moving with constant velocity
the laws of exactly the same way and
this is what it's called the principle
of relativity is their speed limit in
the universe I don't think so you can go
as fast as you want
prob'ly could we go as fast as light I'm
sure eventually absolutely can you
compare the speed of sound and the speed
of light eyes and whatever many times
quicker isn't it because you got the
lightning of lightning and thunder
roughly how much quicker is is roughly
ten times ten times I think is a ten or
a hundred I don't know something like
that the answer for you is a million
it's light as a million times faster
than Sam perhaps thought or thought is
faster than light yeah it's immediate
it's there let's do a little thought
experiment let's say I'm on a train
traveling speed of light that way Who am
I kidding this is City Rail we're lucky
to be moving but let's use our
imagination so let's say I'm traveling
at the speed of light this way if I hold
up a mirror in front of my face will I
be able to see my reflection do you see
the problem in order for me to see my
reflection light has to bounce off my
face and travel to the mirror but if the
mirror is going forwards at the speed of
light how is the light ever going to
catch up
so a logical answer would be that no you
can't see your face in a mirror when
you're on a train traveling at the speed
of life but that violates the principle
of relativity because it means that I
can tell I'm in a frame of reference
that's going at the speed of light that
way crap not again so let's consider the
other option maybe I do see my
reflection which means the light must
travel from my face to the mirror at its
regular speed the speed of light but now
the problem is someone outside the train
would see light traveling at twice the
speed of light because I'm already
traveling at the speed of light and the
light is traveling at the speed of light
relative to me if that makes any sense
so that leads to a really inconsistent
answer because how can the speed of
light be twice the speed of light in
that frame of reference so Einstein's
conclusion was that I must see my
reflection because otherwise it violates
the principle of relativity but in order
for me inside the Train to measure the
same speed of light as someone outside
the Train the Train must actually
contract in the direction that it's
moving and my time must tick by slower
relative to someone outside so Einstein
changed what we thought were absolutes
space and time and made something that
seemed like it should be relative the
speed of light into the true universal
constant so what would it look like to
travel alongside a beam of light
well according to Einstein we'll never
know because we can't go that fast at
that speed our length would become zero
prime would stop relative to an outside
observer and perhaps worst of all our
mass would become infinite but a recent
experimental result has suggested that
neutrinos can go faster than light
still most physicists think that well
this result probably won't hold up to
scrutiny because the principle of
relativity is just so well-established
nowadays but who knows perhaps one day
we'll find a way to break what we
thought was the universal speed limit
the speed of light